good morning John I'm a little bit
freaked out by all the dying birds and
now that thousands of birds have fallen
prey to this bizarre and seemingly
unprecedented event I have found several
entirely insane theories about what
happened to them most of them have to do
with secret government weapons programs
whether it be acoustical or like very
specified biological weapons delivery
and I really just have to say those are
almost the most boring conspiracy
theories I have ever heard I'm not even
going to tell you the details of these
conspiracy theories because they've got
no hot spot they take no pleasure in
their own absurdity
so John I've put together a list of the
top five most ridiculous conspiracy
theories of all time
conspiracy theories that should make
these lame bird conspiracy theories feel
ashamed of themselves
number one the Phantom time hypothesis
which postulates that the years between
614 and 900 something ad never happened
a group of people made those years up
along with everything that ever happened
during those years and all of the
artifacts that date back to those years
Charlemagne for example is of course a
fictional character you thought this was
the year 2011 turns out it's it's 1714
makes you feel young again number two
Nazi UFOs I love this one because you
take UFOs already a conspiracy theory
and you say that that's not enough
because it turns out that Nazis had UFOs
as early as 1930 and before the end of
World War two they took all of their
UFOs and they've been on a secret base
in Antarctica and ever since then those
UFOs have been rummaging around the
earth bothering country folk in their
nightgowns brilliant was I could think
of crazy crap like that
number three Kentucky Fried Chicken
causes sterility but only in black men
this prize-winner dates back to the
1950s back when the KKK was still
powerful Colonel Sanders rumored to have
been a Klansmen himself created a secret
recipe of seven herbs and spices and a
fertility agent that only sterilized
black men while leaving white men as
virile as the Horn of an African rhino
number four Microsoft's secret
wing-dings of terror so Microsoft has
this font it's called wingding it's it's
basically an easy way to get clipart out
of a font you type in symbols come up
for example if you type of capital NYC
you get this which implies of course
killing Jews is a-ok it was actually a
big enough deal that when Microsoft
later released webdings they actually
did embed a secret message into it with
web things if you type in NYC you get I
heart and a city skyline and number five
the reptilian nodes the winner of the
most freakin stupid crazy conspiracy of
all time goes to the guy who came up
with the shape-shifting blood-drinking
you an order up to aliens that have been
ruling the human race since the time of
the Pharaohs Dave pic or former
professional soccer player and morning
show sportscaster has many followers
including the father of balloon boy
Falcon Heene who believed that many of
the most powerful people in human
history are in fact shape-shifting
blood-drinking reptilians from the
constellation Draco the British royal
family most of America's presidents and
of course Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
all reptilians they feed on human guilt
fear and aggression and in order to
maintain their humanoid shape they must
drink lots and lots of human blood
here's a direct quote from his website
Al Gore
vice-president to Clinton Illuminati
Satanist serious blood drinker and
reptilian shapeshifter those are my top
five most ridiculous conspiracy theories
of all time if by chance you thought
that some of those theories did not seem
far-fetched I would request that you go
see a therapist John I'll see you on
Wednesday
endscreen time thank you to my friend
Jesslyn shields for helping you write
and research this there's a link to her
blog in the doobly-doo and thank you too
Toby of Tobuscus Pam for the epic Toby
voice in the intro also one of my
favorite books of the year ship breaker
just won the Printz award which I'm very
excited about congratulations to pala
becae gallupi and there are other things
around me that you should go check out
thank you to nerdfighters for always
being awesome